good afternoon everyone
welcome to this the final session of the
first cca here at hillsdale college
my name is mark nussbaum i'm the
chairman of the chemistry department but
also more appropriately or more more to
the point dean of faculty
here at hillsdale college so
today is the faculty roundtable as we
wrap up the cca and so i'll introduce
our faculty members
in just a moment
so
as as you all know
this cca has obviously been about the
first world war
the timing obviously is linked to the
fact that we are now at the
100 year
centennial if you will of the beginning
of world war one
and the timing of this cca also happens
to fall at a very appropriate time in
our own history in that
tomorrow of course is the 13th
anniversary of 9 11
the terrorist attack on the world trade
center in the pentagon and
tonight
we have an address from our president on
how to deal with isis or isil the
terrorist group that
is lately in the news and particularly
brutal
so
again the timing uh is especially apt it
seems to be talking about some of these
things
so
today this this roundtable session
provides us with an opportunity to
reflect on what we've learned uh and
what uh questions what insights may have
come up through
the the talks that we've heard uh
through this week through the cca and
opportunity also for you
to ask questions or come up
bring your own comments forward as we
have a q a session after the
presentations
so anyway again the topic the cca has
been world war one or the great war or
as it sometimes was called the war to
end all wars
ironically
which immersed europe in
blood bodies and shell shock a century
ago the timing again of this cca is
particularly apt because of
the terrorist threats that uh we see
around us and the fact that world war
one began with a a terrorist act
the the assassination carried out by
terrorists uh that led to the uh
invasion of serbia and pulling in of
various allies
so
uh today terrorists continue to wreak
havoc and draw the attention of major
military forces including our own
in addition just as austria-hungary
threatened serbia
powerful nations in our time continue to
threaten much weaker nations and
potentially thereby draw allied forces
into some sort of conflict for example
think of russia and the ukraine
so in some ways the world is much the
same as it was in 1914 full of greed
evil and fear
but in many crucial ways
the world is vastly different
technology has brought us to the point
where
absolute annihilation is possible
where weapons of destruction can be
delivered virtually anywhere at any time
where information or misinformation
can be transmitted around the globe and
to millions of people almost instantly
and where nebulous terrorist groups and
even individuals
have the power to disrupt nations and
economies at unexpected times and places
whether through computer hacking
publicly aired beheadings as we've seen
recently or suicide bombings in
marketplaces
even when governments are at the center
of a conflict we know that extremist
terrorist organizations are in the
shadows waiting to move in if we happen
to create a power vacuum
so what do we know and what can we learn
from the horrors of the great war 100
years ago
we've had several excellent speakers
address us this week on the causes the
leadership
the poetry the trench warfare the ending
and the aftermath of world war one and
with that background what have we
learned what questions remain and how do
we use this food for thought to nurture
wisdom and direction for the present and
the future
to help us in our thinking we have a few
faculty members here to lead us in a
round table discussion and q and a
sessions so let me begin by introducing
them
dr marie claire morelik is professor of
french here at hillsdale
and originally is from france
her ba is from the college of st
catherine her mat from portland state
university and she earned her phd from
the university of oregon
she's been a member of the hillsdale
faculty since 1995.
dr samuel negis is a visiting assistant
professor of history who joined us at
hillsdale a year ago
he earned his ba from the university of
bristol in 2003
his m.a from georgia state university in
2005 and his phd from texas christian
university in 2013
and finally dr tom connor on my far left
you're right is professor of history and
holds the william p harris chair in
military history here at hillsdale he
has a ba from elizabethtown college and
his ma and phd are from the university
of north carolina he's been here at
hillsdale since 1983.
each faculty member will now give a
brief synopsis of their reflections on
the cca in world war one and we'll move
from one to the next without further
introduction i'll then open the floor to
questions from the audience which may be
directed to the panel as a whole or to
any individual member so we'll proceed
now with brief brief remarks from each
dr morelik
thank you mark
uh tca on world war one thanks to all
the talented speakers we heard has
explored different facets and issues
relating to the great war i was
particularly touched by dr show walter's
talk on the stalemates of the trenches
which gave us a clear view of what it
meant for soldiers to fight this war of
attrition a war wrongfully and
hopelessly called by the french the day
of
which means the last of the last wars
as a professor of french literature who
loves history but is not a historian my
interest in world war one derives from
both having heard and read about it
my entire adult life but mostly as a
granddaughter from having always known
that my grandfather fought at verda
as you can see on the slide france is a
small country compared to the us
the u.s population was around 100
million people in 1914. france had
almost 42 million people in 1914 a
number that shrank down to
38 million or so by 1918.
between a million five and two million
soldiers were killed over four million
were injured
all frenchmen between the age of 18 and
46 were mobilized and were sent to fight
this war
let me tell you about brittany my native
land and i'll show you it is oh this
works
it is in this area here that you can see
it's not very big maybe about as large
as southern michigan this part
and here and i come from this area here
born here
three million people lived in brittany
in 1914 a region mostly uh farmers and
fishermen in 1914
350 000
of britain's if you'd like were
mobilized to serve in the french army
many of these men did not speak french
only
a language connected to welsh and gaelic
because of the army's censorship they
were not allowed to write home in their
native language
they had to find someone who could write
in french and when their letters arrived
home someone who spoke french had to
translate them into for their family
uh by the way uh this is another topic
but their correspondence is incredibly
interesting and i would encourage you to
read some of those letters by the
as they were called by the french um
there was a french soldier of world war
one
because most of these men were farmers
the french army considered that they
were perfectly suited for warfare in the
trenches and were often chosen to be
sent to the most exposed and treacherous
parts of the front in other words they
were expandable
it is estimated that by the end of the
war at least a hundred and thirty
thousand proton soldiers died maybe as
many as two hundred thousand and that
over four hundred thousand survived who
had been injured once or several times
in battle
these are some of the soldiers of the
118th
infantry regiment in which several of
the men in my family served
a regiment was made up of
3250 men and 120 officers
the
118th
regiment lost
2991
men in battle
probably twice as many were injured
this number means if i understand
correctly that this regimen suffered
around 300 percent casualties
now let me introduce to you members of
my family
this is the puen family on the left
hopefully i will be able to
anyway
uh all four sons my great uncles went to
war
even joseph who is the small boy on the
left
who turned 18 in 1917.
the other three sons were mobilized in
1914. jean-francois on the left
was in the postal service jamari
next to his sister francoise
was taken prisoner and sent to the camp
of minden in germany in 1915. he
returned home very weakened by the tough
living conditions at the camp
eve
on the right
next to his sister francoise
joined the 19th regiment of infantry
which is the other regiment from
brittany my grandmother yvonne who is
the little girl
and her sister francoise the older girl
and their parents worked the farm during
the entire war
in 1918 my great uncles gave my
grandmother as a token of their
affection and gratitude for keeping the
farm together the brooch i'm wearing
today
my grandmother already knew my
grandfather louis mohelek is not there
yet
when he was sent to the front in 1914 in
fact they had always known each other
the two of them did their first
communion together
and because they were both first in
their catechism class they walked to the
altar together a sure sign according to
my grandmother that they were meant to
be together
so in 1914
hazy was ready to go home following four
years of mandatory military service from
1910 to 1914
the war broke out
he was always he was already engaged to
my grandmother but did not want to marry
her until war was over not wanting to
make her her widow his regiment 118th
regiment fought in the ardennes
verdant the medium twice
the sum twice and the champagne region
in 1916 he was wounded in the leg near
fort duomo
close to verdan
after recovering from his injury he was
sent right back to his regiment and
consequently to the front sometime later
he escaped death another time thanks to
a leather pouch within it a watch a
rosary and a medal of notre dame de
carnitone
which prevented a large piece of
shrapnel from penetrating his abdomen
he received a citation for bravery in
september 1918 when he was in champaign
when the war ended it was sent to
luxembourg to participate in the
restoration of the palace because he was
a trained painter and decorator
he finally went home in 1919 after nine
years of absence started his own
business and married my grandmother in
1921.
their story does not end there because
less than two decades later world war ii
broke out and brittany was occupied by
the german army
because they live near the coast they
survived despite the ordeal of the
german occupation
as a little girl that's me there that
little one
i remember my grandfather a wonderful
man
participated in every commemoration of
the 11th of november holding the french
flag of the 118th regiment in front of
the monument to the dead
erected in the middle of town
the names of many soldiers many of whom
had been his friends were inscribed on
the monument
he never spoke of the war
most of what i know i was told by my
father and my uncle and also through
some personal research
but i do remember that when we went to
the beach
as he rolled up the bottom of his pants
to play with us
we could see a deep scar in one of his
legs i also know that after the war as
many other briton soldiers did he went
on pilgrimages to thank god and the
virgin mary for allowing him to survive
the war
there are so many more stories to tell
about world war one
and every single french family has at
least one
thank you for listening
in the most famous passage of william
faulkner's 1948 novel intruder in the
dust gavin stevens captures the
intensity and agony of pickett's charge
in southern memory musing to his nephew
charles it's all now you see yesterday
won't be over until tomorrow and
tomorrow began 10 000 years ago for
every southern boy 14 years old not once
but whenever he wants it there is an
instant when it's still not yet two
o'clock on that july afternoon of 1863
it hasn't even begun yet it not only
hasn't begun yet but there is still time
for it not to begin
the analogous moment in the historical
consciousness
of british boys is 7 30 a.m on the 1st
of july 1916.
we are standing on the firing step
hoping hoping that the seven day
artillery barrage has done its work in
killing the opposing enemy cutting his
wire and destroying his defenses
we hope for a great perhaps even
decisive victory
and now our officers are blowing their
whistles for the advance and within an
hour german machine guns claimed twenty
thousand casualties sixty thousand
killed and wounded by nightfall the
bloodiest day in british history for
gains to be measured in mere yards
memorialization of the battle began
before the campaign even concluded an
official documentary filmed the battle
of the somme consisting of footage shot
at the front appeared first in cinemas
in late august and 20 million britons
had viewed it within two months
a widely read battlefield tour book
appeared uh shortly after the end of
1917.
once the war ended focus soon shifted
from simply remembering to explaining
and inevitably of course excusing the
bloodshed members of the ruling liberal
liberal government including premise
david lloyd george when his memoirs
appeared in 1933 rushed to blame
military commanders for strategic
disasters in 1927 another former cabinet
member winston churchill wrote in his
history the world crisis that quote the
military conceptions underlying the
scheme of attack were characterized by
simplicity british and french commanders
had selected as the point of their
offensive what was undoubtedly the
strongest and most perfectly defended
position in the world
a growing chorus of veterans echoed such
sentiments increasingly invoking a sense
of regret loss and thorough
pointlessness
the poet edward blunden wrote in his
1929 essay the psalm still flows that
quote by the end of the day both sides
had seen in a sad scrawl of broken earth
and murdered men that there was no road
no thoroughfare neither race had won nor
could win the war the war had won and
would go on winning what had been begun
on july 1st became a slow slaughtering
process a fatal quicksand into which
division after division was drawn down
in time especially once the second world
war provided the contrast of a decisive
war fought in a more obviously noble
cause such reflections came to dominate
british scholarly consensus
in his 1963 illustrated history of the
war ajp taylor asserted that quote
nothing had been learned from previous
failures except how to repeat them on a
larger scale idealism perished on the
psalm and set the picture by which
future generations saw the first world
war brave helpless soldiers blundering
obstinate generals nothing achieved such
works perhaps none more so than alan
clark's concise but powerful monograph
the donkeys formed the cultural memory
of a generation of school boys including
the comedian ben elton who would go on
later to write the celebrated bbc sitcom
black adder which i have literally
assigned to my students to watch as
homework
in the first episode of the final season
set in the trenches of the great war
captain blackout appears out into no
man's land through a periscope and
bleakly states my instincts lead me to
deduce that we're at last about to go
over the top a which is more
enthusiastic and patriotic lieutenant
george exclaims great scots sir do you
mean the mean of moans finally arrived
for us to give harry hun a darn good
british-style thrashing six of the best
trousers down
to which black had a response with
characteristic dryness if you mean are
we all going to get killed yes
clearly field marshal hague is about to
make yet another gargantuan effort to
move his drinks cabinet six inches
closer to berlin
since the late 20th century a growing
chorus of military historians have
challenged this established narrative
arguing that allied commanders did in
fact learn from the attritional battles
of 1915-17
and that those battles paved the way for
eventual victory by
significantly weakening the central
powers fighting capability
nick lloyd abele represented this view
yesterday afternoon explaining how by
late 1918 the allied high command had
developed and adopted every salient
feature of integrated three-dimensional
warfare
william philpot lloyd's colleague at
king's college has authored the most
powerful recent work of this type
entitled three armies on the song
philpott demonstrated the battles
decisive uh sorry the battles de
devastating impact on a german army
already strained by greater and ongoing
punishment at verdun and he compellingly
argues that british and french forces
did make some appreciable headway on
july 1st which they progressively
exploited thereafter later law he
ascribes to the fact that quote in the
immediate circumstances after proud
virile brave and fervent battalions had
been cut to pieces it seemed easier to
manufacture a myth of heroic sacrifice
than to investigate what had gone wrong
under the conditions of modern war
like max hastings in his sunday evening
presentation philpott utterly rejects
the cynical caricatures of hague and
company as callous half wits unable to
grasp the realities and limitations of
modern war
animating such revisionist scholarship
is a belief that ultimately however
ghastly the cost the allies just cause
stood between europe and a dark future
under german military hegemony
philpot states that quote the imperial
army was an institution molded by and
ideally suited to the kaiser's
belligerent regime militarism was deeply
rooted in germany's history and
traditions even if she did not want to
anticipate a general european war there
are strong grounds for believing that
germany had no intention of backing down
if austro-hungary precipitated one
max hastings echoed this view on sunday
afternoon and stating that quote there
was a cause at stake britain could not
have remained neutral and allowed german
hegemony in europe
hastings further claimed dismissing the
work of nile ferguson with one oblique
reference presumably missed by most that
the only truly untenable thesis is that
war began in 1914 accidentally
in his 1998 monograph the pity of war
which i highly recommend ferguson argues
that the kaiser gambled an all-out war
in 1914 less from an inexorable desire
for military hegemony than a position of
weakness
while germany's pre-war growth in
population and industrial wealth receive
wealth receive frequent comment the
greater rates enjoyed by her mortal
enemy russia go unnoticed equally
forgotten is the level of british
financial investment funding german
industrialization the increasingly
representative nature of german
political institutions is also lost in
the later image of rampant and
insatiably ambitious german militarism
as to the war's causes and germany's
aims ferguson points out that nothing
remotely remembering resembling the
oft-cited september program proposing to
annex most of much of europe to the
right appears in the documentary record
prior to the moment of britain's british
entry into the war on the contrary
kaiser wilhelm repeatedly offered to
guarantee franco belgium in territorial
integrity in exchange for british
neutrality and offer the liberal cabinet
may have rejected for no nobler reason
than political pressure from a rising
conservative opposition they believed
would win a general election if the
crisis of july 1914 brought down lloyd
george's government
thus there is every reason to believe
ferguson argues that an unnecessary war
did begin accidentally and tried the
tried and tested balance of power system
might have been preserved but instead a
peaceful future for an economically
integrated and socially democratic
europe was sacrificed in a pointless
bloodbath productive only of revolution
and future greater wars
in this context the suggestion that some
and other attritional battles taught
valuable lessons appears at best
irrelevant indeed john keegan remarks in
his one volume history of the war that
quote a new generation of young military
historians has taken to refighting the
battles of the british expeditionary
force with a passion more understandable
and survivors of trench warfare
disasters than posthumous academic
analysts the energy expended in such
reconsiderations seems a pointless waste
the simple truth of 1914 18 trench
warfare is that massing large numbers of
soldiers unprotected by anything but
cloth uniforms however they were trained
however equipped against large masses of
other soldiers protected by earthworks
and barbed wire and provided with
rapid-fire weapons was bound to result
in heavy casualties
so this surely in conclusion is the
appropriate response to the bloody
tragedy of the great war the essence of
what max hastings dismissed as quote the
modern misinterpretation of the poet's
view
this is what iva gurney captures in his
poem the target writing my mother she
can't sleep for fear of what might be
happening here to me perhaps it might be
best to die and set her fears at rest
for worse is worse and worries done
perhaps he was the only son yet god
keeps still and does not say a word of
guidance anyway all's a tangle here's my
job a man might rave or shout or sob and
god he takes no sort of heed this is a
bloody mess indeed
revisionist military historians
demonstrate an academically credible
desire to move beyond the simple
familiar emotional cultural responses to
the war and learn broader strategic and
geopolitical lessons but to me an
englishman raised on the war poet's myth
deeply moved and intellectually formed
in boyhood by the work of alan clark and
ever grateful that my great-grandfather
was so fortunate to return from the
psalm alive
this seems wrong-headed
the great war proved almost as
destructive and deceptive disruptive for
cultures that nominally want it as for
those which clearly lost
from the peaceful prosperous and orderly
perspective of 1914 what apocalyptic
european future worth the deaths of 10
million young men to the great war
prevent
could the price of peace negotiated at
any moment prior to 1918 but especially
in july of 1914 possibly have exceeded
the value of the edwardian civilization
lost forever in the mud and gunfire of
the somme
to me the first greatest and only lesson
of the great war will always be that war
almost any war in the name of almost any
cause
is almost inevitably counterproductive
and absolutely one of the very worst
possible uses of young lives
the past three or four days have been a
sheer delight
and it's a pleasure to offer some
remarks as the symposium breaks up i've
got a prepared script like my other two
colleagues but i know we will all
welcome your questions uh afterwards
a number of folks here have commented
about the fact that british speakers
have carried most of the load in this
cca
but it seems absolutely right and
fitting that our cousins from across the
pond should have done just that
americans have certainly contributed
their share of excellent scholarship on
the first world war
and we had dr showalter and dr hansen to
confirm that
but for the opening 33 months of its
52-month duration
the great war was a european conflict
it did not become america's war until
april 1917
so it should not surprise us that
european scholars and as of today the
british do consider themselves europeans
have contributed the lion's share of
historical analysis of the event at
issue for us
this week
neither should it surprise us
that the centennial observance of the
first world war has been in its opening
phase anyway
primarily a european affair
when 2017 and 2018 roll around however
this should change
we should all hope that americans will
then if ever
allow themselves a meaningful marking of
the 100th anniversary of our
participation in this momentous conflict
with that in mind i want to engage
briefly with the very large question of
how and why
should we remember
the first world war
my two colleagues have just provided
wonderful insights into how people in
their native lands
do this
now it's time to address this question
from the perspective of a country
that chose a later moment
to enter the war
but whose forces likely tipped the
balance in favor of the eventual winners
i think we would all agree that
americans are much more familiar with
the second world war than the first and
that we tend to remember what was for us
the 1941 45 conflict
more favorably and more fervently
than we do the 1917-18 struggle
why is this
well i've just indicated that the second
world war engaged us for a far longer
period of time than the first
45 months as an active belligerent in
the later conflict compared with 19 in
the earlier one
more of our countrymen were mobilized to
fight the second war than the first 16
million
compared with four to five million
there are still living veterans in our
midst from the second world war
we've been honored to have some of them
with us in this audience
while there are none still alive
from the first world war
but the reasons why americans don't seem
to remember the first world war like
they do the second run deeper than the
factors just cited i think
the second war was the good war
our enemies in that fight were plainly
evil
and the heroic all-out struggle against
them ended as dr hanson reminded us last
night
with the clear and permanent defeat
of the ideologies they championed
italian fascism german nazism and
japanese militarism
for the past 20 or 30 years moreover
americans have known the generation of
soldiers and civilians who brought home
the victory in world war ii
as the greatest generation
furthermore
the generals in that war
seemed to have real talent
and imagination enough anyway
to win the hearts of their
contemporaries and students of the war
ever since
hollywood directors still make movies
about the second world war while tending
to ignore the first
our presidents never miss
a 10-year d-day anniversary
and an impressive monument to the latter
of the two global conflicts occupies a
privileged place on the national mall in
washington d.c
as for the first world war
it's so easy to remember it as the bad
war
characterized as someone said it earlier
this week
principally by blood
mud
and futility
everyone knows that the first world war
didn't defeat any bad guys permanently
rather it begat more bad guys
bolsheviks
fascists and nazis to name a few
and it also begat bad things
protracted border disputes all over the
world misfit politicians
and economic disasters like the great
depression
as a result
participation in the first world war
disappointed and disillusioned our
people and a lot of others
woodrow wilson seemed to promise that
the war
would yield a world made safe for
democracy and that it might even be the
war to end all wars
we got none of this
and for his efforts
wilson was utterly repudiated by his own
people when the senate rejected
membership in the league of nations and
he served out the final year and a half
of his term as an invalid all but
incommunicado
in the white house
years after our soldiers came home as a
final in dignity
they all but rebelled when they didn't
get the bonuses they felt they'd been
promised
such experiences sound more worthy of
forgetting than remembering
as the years have passed and the world
war one veterans passed away to the last
man
having been decisively upstaged by the
greatest generation
we do seem to have forgotten
in 2010 a year before our last living
veteran of the great war mr frank
buckles died
at age 110
he appeared before a congressional
committee to plead for a monument in the
nation's capital comparable to the one
for world war ii
but to the soldiers and the american
cause in the first world war
his pleas fell on deaf ears
there are magnificent monuments and
beautiful cemeteries honoring american
soldiers and achievements in the great
war on the other side of the atlantic
but they are thousands of miles away
from us here and attract few visitors
even from among the hordes of americans
who travel to europe every summer
who among us
even knows that the bloodiest battle in
american history was the muse argonne
the last battle of the first world war
who among us knows that the largest
american war cemetery in europe
with 14
246 graves
is in northeastern france on the field
of that battle
a site
no american president has ever visited
who among us knows that the only other
american soldier besides george
washington
to be honored by congress with the
exalted rank of general of the
armies was john j pershing
the commander of our forces in the first
world war
how many chicagoans
know
who this man was after whom a
significant boulevard and a major high
school in their city was named
in conclusion it is to be hoped
that the cca which the college has been
so good to sponsor and that you've been
so kind to attend
might spark a renewed interest in the
first world war
and inspire many among us to find our
own ways to honor and remember
the generation of americans who brought
home a victory albeit woefully temporary
and compromised
from that war
a visit to the national world war one
museum in kansas city
a superb creation of the past decade or
so that shares space with one of the
grandest and most important monuments to
the first world war on american soil
would be one way to do that relatively
close to home
it is equally equally to be hoped that
when our country fully mobilizes for its
centennial observance of the great war
many more will become familiar as they
never have been before
with an event that left such an enduring
and taxing mark
on our own time
thank you
thank you uh thank you to each of the
faculty members we'll now open the floor
to questions or comments from the
audience please wait until please raise
your hand and wait until one of the
young ladies brings a microphone to you
and if you could stand and feel free to
address the question to a particular
panelist or to the panel as a whole
thank you
i'm surprised by the lack of comment
upon america's actually joining the war
what were our motives for joining the
war why did we join with a particular
faction that we did and not the central
powers for
instance i'll take a stab at that
um
how we got into the war
if woodrow wilson's explanation of it in
his war message that he delivered to
congress in april 1917 are to be
believed
uh had to do with the
unrestricted submarine warfare campaign
that the germans initiated or actually
they restarted it in january of nineteen
well actually february 1st
1917 the germans had waged unrestricted
submarine warfare earlier in the war
that had resulted in among other uh
events the uh sinking of the lusitania
the british ocean liner in may of 1915.
but uh when when the germans went back
to that
they began sinking american ships at sea
and that gave wilson a pretext in his
own war message to declare basically the
germans to be the enemies of humanity
and to denounce the war that they were
waging at sea as a war against all
humanity and in that case we just had to
be in it
there was also the matter of the
zimmerman telegram
which was revealed to the americans
early in 1917
that was a german dispatch containing
a an invitation
that germany made to the mexican
government to ally with germany and
fight the united states in in the event
that the german return to unrestricted
warfare submarine warfare brought the
united states into the war in which case
if mexico allied with germany and won
the war then the mexicans could have
taken back
essentially the southwestern quadrant of
the united states which they had lost to
us in the mexican war in the 1840s so
those were the the announced pretext but
there's been a lot of speculation
that wilson uh
was itching to get us into the war that
he wanted the united states to have a
seat at the peace conference for example
that the only way we were going to get
that was to become an active belligerent
at some point
and uh there
in the 20s and 30s the theory developed
in the american public that it was
american businesses that were conspiring
to push the government into the war the
merchants of death
so-called who were looking to rescue
their investment from a possible german
defeat in the first world war in which
case we never would have gotten our
loans back
uh if france and britain had lost so
it's it's a complex story but i i think
wilson made his best case for war in the
war message that i just
highlighted
um
i
doctor that's a very able answer and uh
i i
the short answer to that question is
four words long
woodrow wilson's messiah complex
if if you want the long answer you can
enroll in history 487 next fall
but that that it'll basically just be a
longer version of that
um
this question is probably more of dr
nussbaum's alley but any of the um
faculty members can answer it um
what do you think of the development and
use of the chemical weapons during world
war one uh how did they work how did
they um
how were they weaponized were they
originally
intended or were they originally
developed to be used as means of warfare
or was it just uh something that they
saw could be used for that
any comments would be appreciated
well
although i'm a chemist i'm certainly not
an expert on chemical warfare and i
imagine there's others here who would be
able to comment more about that just
briefly
it it's an interesting issue because
um
initially as as one of the speakers
mentioned when they were first used the
chemical weapons were simply uh you know
gases that were let loose and let blow
in the wind when the wind was blowing in
the right direction and then as time
went on they became more
more capably delivered i guess
i think world war one because of that
use of chemical weapons
began to raise the question that that we
face even more prominently now is that
when
when we have a weapon
that's capable of
you know horrific destruction and loss
of life
when or if
do we use it in other words under what
circumstances is it justified and
justifiable and
obviously that becomes even more uh more
prominent on people's minds as we enter
the nuclear age and so forth and you
know that's one of the things that up
until i guess i would say up until world
war one and someone can correct me if
i'm wrong um
we we didn't really i don't think
warring parties ever really had that
that
major of a weapon in their hands that it
was uh you know well gee this is this is
going to be uh not just devastating to
to soldiers but to
you know whole area
so at some point
i think uh begins to raise the ethical
questions of you know are there weapons
that are just too horrible to to use but
let me turn it over to again some of the
others here because again my my um
limited information or or expertise on
this is uh probably less than theirs
well if if i may let me uh just give dr
nussbaum a
cue there were three different kinds of
gas that the germans used
chlorine was the first i believe that
debuted in 1915
and fosgene gas debuted in 1916
and then in 1917 mustard gas
came into use and i
it's always been my understanding that
the properties of the gases got more
severe more lethal
as the progression unfolded but uh when
the germans first used gas and of course
they weren't the only ones to to use it
ultimately but when the germans first
did use it in april 1915 they they used
it against canadian forces up in
flanders second battle of ypra
and the
forces on the receiving end panicked and
left a huge opening in the line but the
germans were
so unschooled in what they could expect
from the use of the weapon that they did
not exploit
the advantage that it initially caused
so that was a comment that was made a
number of times all week how difficult
it was for
the
warring parties to come up with
technology to break the stalemate but
even when they did come up with the
technology they didn't fully comprehend
what it could do but if chlorine fosgene
and mustard gas trigger anything about
the specific properties of those gases
that
yeah perhaps going down we have to defer
i mean i know there's others in the
audience that could probably give more
uh detailed information as far as the
properties of those particular games you
don't make them in your lab is that
well yeah we
we try to avoid those uh none of them
none of them are pleasant that's for
sure
a couple of the speakers over the past
uh few days have cited uh neil
ferguson's view that the british would
have been better off not entering the
war but there's also a view popular in
uh
libertarian circles
uh these days that the americans would
have been better and perhaps the world
would have been better off had the
united states not entered the war the
theory being that
uh ultimately the
britain france and germany would have
had to have
negotiated a settlement just from sheer
exhaustion
and that all of the bad things that
happened in germany and russia
thereafter would have been prevented
would any of you care to comment on that
yeah um i since i was the one who who
raised niall ferguson favorably i
suppose i'll take the first stab at it
um and i'm also a scholar of american
foreign relations and a not so closet
libertarian so i suppose uh that would
that would be me
um
well
first of all
i mean
when you talk about what would have
happened you're always uh you're always
in very difficult waters to say the
absolute least
the only thing you can talk about for
with any certainty is is what did happen
and then you can always make it a very
tentative educated guess about one
step away from what happened and
thereafter you're sort of speaking to
blackness
um
would the united states have have been
have been better off like all things i
suppose it depends on your perspective
and what your priorities are
what did happen as a result of of u.s
entry into the war let me give you my
answer as an englishman who was raised
on all of the full bitterness of the
first world war uh
poet's myth you know my history high
school history teacher
nigel gallup i still remember him uh
pointing me towards alan clark and
telling me to go home and read this book
the donkeys and i was just telling dr
connor the other day i can still
visualize myself at the age of about 15
sitting in my bedroom
reading that book on the floor i
couldn't put it down and i i was you
know all but weeping reading it
and now here i am as a naturalized
american having gravitated from the uh
thatcherite conservatism of my youth to
uh as you may or may not have gathered
from my paper a rather dovish brand of
american libertarianism so this is my
answer as as me as my priorities and
what i care about
but what did happen
a staggering degree of new
marginally constitutional at best war
powers accumulated by the
american government which of course is
necessary to fight a war uh
what did george washington say in the
farewell address
large military establishments are
inauspicious to liberty in any form of
government but most especially in a
republic and and and so what do you get
by the end of the war a massive army an
enormous array of precedents for uh
unconstitutional power grabs by the
federal government of which franklin
roosevelt will make uh far more
extensive and enthusiastic use when his
time comes and perhaps worst of all you
get a narrative you get a narrative that
maybe all woodrow was right after all
and and the nation turned against him
and that the tragedy of the second world
war is the failure to live up to and
fulfill the wilsonian dream and here we
have a second bite of the cherry and so
1945 becomes the rebirth of the
wilsonian vision and you have the cold
war and everything that comes after it
with the growth of the national security
state and now the government is reading
your emails and it never reads the
constitution
and and why because we went abroad
looking for monsters to destroy
um
and sure perhaps my great grandfather
wouldn't have made it if the americans
hadn't come along i personally am glad
that they did from the perspective of an
englishman who had a hard time learning
german when i was a boy and so
presumably it would have been even worse
if it had been foisted upon me as a baby
but
answering is an american
constitutionalist and again it is only
my perspective and nothing more
uh yes i think it would have been a very
good idea not to get involved in that
bloody awful
show um
i'm i'm not going to take an opposing
point of view to that i i think
the upshot of of dr naga's comment there
are a number of upshots i guess but uh
wars are
uh
an awful way ultimately a futile way to
bring about new world order
um that was that's one of the many
lessons i think that we can take out of
woodrow wilson's
management you might say of the american
effort in the first world war but and
i've had a love-hate relationship i must
say with woodrow wilson for most of my
life
a good part of me admires his idealism
and the other part of me um recoils at
how ineffectual
that idealism was and perhaps even it
got results exactly the opposite
of what he'd hoped but i i think for the
purpose of this discussion i'll come
down very simply on the side that yeah i
think if the united states didn't get
into the war hadn't gotten into the war
the outcome might have been different
and that that might not have been such a
good thing
in in the long run
i think we have time just for one more
question please
um
on okay there we go um dr connor had
mentioned the
failure to recognize world war one on
the same scale as world war ii
um and i was wondering anyone can answer
whether this is linked to some
deliberate renunciation of not only the
horrors of the first world war but some
of the principles as well possibly
something like ardent nationalism
um
i'd like to hear dr morlek speak to that
and i'll prattle on a little while but
but i think what what you heard from her
is how much
more alive
remembrances are of of the first world
war and then the whole process of of
remembering is in in france
compared with with what it is here and i
think it really does depend on the
national perspective
i think
memory of the first world war and the
active remembering of it is is more
alive in britain certainly than it is in
the united states i don't mean to
suggest that the british
tend to lean toward one war or the other
in in terms of where the bulk of their
remembrance uh goes the french had of
course a
a very different experience unique
experience in the second world war
but um
marie claire would you take that up and
just kind of talk a general way about
you know how the french well do you
remember i'm not a historian so i really
hesitate to answer this type of question
however i think maybe what i can say
is that
i never heard for example in my family
it's never been a matter of nationalism
it was a matter of duty this man who
went to this war
were not
were doing it as a duty serving their
country and i don't think they were
necessarily
highly i mean politically motivated in
trying to establish one thing or another
i think they were really obeying orders
a lot and and really fighting to serve
their country that's a feeling i've
always had in terms of how my family
reacted or my grandparents or even the
sense of you know how you love your
country
so it was not to establish
i never got that feeling anyway that it
was to establish
a
more nationalistic
uh
i don't know mentality or
value of view no i never had that
feeling at all
but it was a disastrous war every single
family was affected by it but they still
did what they had to do
so that's about all i can say i don't
know maybe you can help with that
i think that covers it
okay i think we'll close with that if
any of you would like to stay around i'm
sure the panelists would be willing to
stick around for a little bit if you
have additional questions you'd like to
discuss with them thank you very much
for attending the cca
enjoy the rest of the day
good stuff